when it comes to Japanese metalwork
knives usually get all the glory but in
the city of Sakai where blacksmithing
goes back to the making of samurai
swords in the 14th century one craftsman
has built a legacy on something a little
different
scissors to split paper food and of
course bonsai trees
this is the a su héroe hirokawa who
works under the brand Suzuki we Akiane
hasami toka for jokes with guru hana
kasi honest
[Music]
hirokawa is a fifth-generation scissor
maker and he has been doing it for half
a century
he is the only traditional scissor
craftsman left in all of Japan Okayama
state killing machine idle domina do you
know gamma which one was rushed you know
something the my children joy and I also
feel Samuel with a super ball well I
will put up an army time is evil to the
talents me few thousand I will cut that
schedule it's good they are about yoga
[Music]
it takes hirokawa a week or longer
working ten hours a day to make a pair
of scissors three to four times as long
as making a knife and that effort is
reflected in the price well honey the
one they're down in Devon most so no no
no they do any myself so that I know how
some devil original toka cotton also get
a lot but what are you gonna do with
scissors that expensive to answer that
here's Masakazu Yoshi couch a craftsman
of bonsai for a master like yoshikawa a
key in crafting perfect bonsai is the
perfect pair of scissors schizont oh
they know it's good to morones get them
all to Geneva yaku Sasuke Santo this is
economy arataura after know what I see
Nardini kinky soukara
a body honto she eaten a chicken
cacciatore story
[Music]
da da da Cunha psychoanalyst the body he
has a mute scarknight Oh double
autonomous nobody in her family Arriba
I know so Kubasaki Tatum also go to need
dummies you Italian equation kitty could
see a spot to get in there and yoshikawa
still remembers his first pair of Suzuki
scissors nobody will know more on
another to know more neighborhood is Eva
how can you do you know a hotel/motel
told another that is Cara Maria dismay
sono hitomi amor datura
evolves Aleta unanimously but for
hirokawa he's only just gotten started
the in question until not a night in my
email was hypocritical Dohan gusty
Conchita madam Jami teriyaki dominated
clean IEDs
[Music]